the big fallout after the Oscars you
don't think the Oscars are gonna happen
and then someone's not going to get in
trouble on on the Twitter do you the
onion tweeted about I got to get her
name right quoi avenging a Wallace as
she was in beasts of the southern wild
and she's the 9 year old actress and
well let's put up the the tweet at the
onion everyone else seems afraid to say
it but that quoi then Jimmy Wallace is
kind of a c-word right okay there it is
thank God for my phonetics where Kelly
I'm gonna start with you on this one
because language comedy these are things
you're very interested in your father
George Carlin is the Godfather of both
of those babies seven or fifty filthy
words the list keeps getting big good
sexually which he would be very upset by
where should we start with this take it
away well first of all when I saw this
today I thought this is this is the
living room joke this isn't the Twitter
joke this is the joke that someone comes
up with it in the living room who's very
high who's been doing bong hits all
night long probably a few shots and they
turn around and it's one of my more
irreverent comedian friends and they say
it and we all laugh because we all know
it's not true it's not what it's about
it's about Hollywood it's about you know
people are impossible and clearly this
girl's not impossible but this is not
something you tweet yeah and and you
know and I and I just it would have been
okay if Gilbert Godfried had tweeted it
because then he would have apologized
right away and everything would have
been okay yeah I might have a college
eyes buffet line
and then after again yeah now this and
then today people are like bringing my
dad's name up with this and then of
course they asked me what would he think
and I don't know he's dead I you know
it's I don't know I these days I just
don't know anymore about jokes it's all
it's either to PC or were to I ran out
of words I think you didn't want to
offend anybody
right Fred woody what do you think about
this you know it's it's a reference to
child stars and many of us have worked
with them but very obviously very
inappropriate I think there should be a
moratorium on using the c-word on anyone
who was born this millennium and she was
born in 2003 yeah I think if you go
nineties and before her okay 90s prior
to that think so c-word okay so this is
an age issue basically what you seem to
be for a lot of people are right 90 if
everything being equal if this had been
said about Ann Coulter I'm pretty sure
that and that an apology would have not
had been issued all right
retweet retweet you can only reach me
once kept retweets you have started
other twittering like fake Aaron Foley I
wouldn't I wouldn't even call her the
see I would never I mean that's what it
is it's like you know you gotta have
maybe like a some Twitter filter like a
draft or like yeah yeah high five your
buddy and then you go yeah but I'm you
know not a complete idiot you know it's
it's so outrageous that which is
alarming too because the onion I mean
who doesn't love the onion they've like
the smartest like they don't need to do
any of that like they're so above that
and they're interesting I was tweeting
like crazy last night and it's a snark
fest and it's what you do during these
live events and you know and I always
feel dirty afterwards because I know
I've said a few things that I wouldn't
normally say and but I felt like like
I'd been on a cocaine binge afterwards
so I'm thinking possibly this person
just kind of didn't really realize how
out of bounds it was and it went out
there and this person has been fired
from the onion now which is weird well
speaking of being fired so of course the
onion did issue an apology because this
is America in 2013 and everyone has to
apologize for something so let's let's
take a look at the apology itself dear
readers on behalf of the onion I offer
my personal apology to clubs aren t know
Wallis and the Academy of Motion Picture
Arts and Sciences for the tweet that was
circulated last night during the Oscars
it was crude and offensive not to
mention inconsistent with the onions
commitment to parody and satire
however biting no person should ever be
subjected to such a shame a senseless
humorless comment masquerading as satire
the tweet was taken down within an hour
of publication we have instituted new
and tighter Twitter procedures to ensure
that this kind of mistake does not occur
again etc etc and this is from the onion
CEO Steve Hanna the interesting word
here that I think we should focus on is
the word mistake because if had the
reaction been different while no one
would have thought this was a mistake
and that's the fine line that comedians
have to play on how do you deal with
that when you're when you're writing
jokes and you're on stage how do you
deal with that well I don't use the
c-word I kind of reel that in yeah so
many times where I'm like that would be
the best punchline and then I'm like no
I got to rewrite that so I can still
have a career but yeah I mean honest to
god I think it went too far they
apologized for in my book I'm like the
guy I know the guy or woman it's a guy
need to be fired it's some radik all
right it was a bad call you take it down
you apologize you move on like the fact
that it's still going on all that but
you know just wrap it up you know that's
funny the world assuming that it's a man
yeah what if it was a woman because it
could have been because you know women
have opinions about other women and
especially women who are you know
considered and the c-word yeah
you know but one thing I know that my
dad did say about this is that the
comedian's job is to find the edge and
cross it that is their job
and they did find an image and they and
they crossed it last night okay great
now we know where that edge is but then
again going after a nine-year-old child
yeah that's and that's an edge that I'm
not quite sure you even want to look for
out of like maybe throw like you
know you could have tried the joke at
another way as well I think you know
apologize for that latter he said
tighter Twitter in their controls and
tight tighter didn't he say that sounds
like sound might have to apologize he's
gonna have to apologize for that
beautiful letter of apology
and don't forget bonobos calm is the
official outfitter of the Rueben report
enter code Rueben report for 20% off
your first purchase